the road trip is a journey that most
people think is swell but what they do
not realize is that it also can be hell
and if you do not think the things I'm
saying ring most true to you let me tell
you of events that will most definitely
ensue you'll start out happy never
better as you're speeding ever forward
but in about an hour's time you'll have
become completely bored that is when
you're not calling other drivers stupid
though I guess you can have fun with all
those trucks
it's a rough vacation driving across the
nation but you'll find some motivation
from your liquid stimulation then you're
backed up urination causes your friend
such frustration while they're sleeping
patterns tend to test your patience and
the hotel rooms that you stay in are all
disgusting and the diet of fast food
well it makes you smell disgusting you
laughs way to pardon exit 16i and i tell
you this then you'll get in fights while
driving and she'll be so very pissed but
she'll make up and risk other's lives so
you can steal a kiss and watch all your
money go to Tollbooth straight-out up
your fists don't take lots of instagrams
and you'll touch strangers scene outside
you'll lead oratorios and beat cosmos
even guys you'll slowly lose your mind
and you'll feel
on the inside all because you thought
you should take a 30 hour ride all these
things will happen if you drives a very
far and when you get there you will
celebrate and never want to do that
again